(lively music)
- [Narrator] You are looking
at the demographic breakdown
of China and India's populations.
In 1990, both countries'
demographics resembled a pyramid
which meant that there were far
more young people being born
than there were old people.
But fast forward to projections for 2050
and you'll notice a dramatic change.
The Chinese pyramid
narrows to resemble a shape
more like a funnel.
For more than two centuries,
China has had the largest
population in the world.
This year, the UN said
India will take its place.
India's population is
expected to keep growing
for the next four decades,
peaking at nearly 1.7 billion in 2063.
China's population is
projected to shrink rapidly.
By the start of the next century,
India's population is expected
to be double that of China's.
- All the science point
to a very challenging future
for China, demographically.
- [Narrator] Here's why this
shift marks a watershed moment
for both nations
and what the change could
mean for the global economy.
This year, China announced
its first population decline since 1961.
In 2020, China's fertility rate
or the number of children a
woman has over her lifetime
came in at 1.3 which is one
of the lowest in the world.
The roots of China's
demographic crisis can be found
in its one child policy.
- The policy was designed
to keep birth low
so that China would have the opportunity
to grow its economy.
It turns out, in reality,
the one child policy has
far more long lasting impacts
the policy makers intended.
In a way, it worked too well.
- [Narrator] Starting in 1980,
most Chinese couples were
strictly limited to one child.
Despite reversing the
one child policy in 2016,
China's fertility rate
is continued to decline.
- The replacement rate needed
to keep a population stable is 2.1.
- [Narrator] Meaning that a
woman would need to give birth
to at least two children to
keep the population stable
and essentially replace the parents.
With a fertility rate of 2.0,
India's fertility rate is slightly lower
than the replacement rate.
- The reason why India's
population is projected
to keep growing for several
more decades is because India,
unlike China, still has a
fairly large group of women
of reproductive age that's
very different from China.
- [Narrator] In China,
the one child policy
produced a dramatic gender imbalance
that originated in strong
cultural and social preferences
for male children.
In 2021, the number of marriage
registrations plummeted
to 7.6 million,
the lowest since the government
started keeping records
in the mid 1980s.
The global economy has grown
to rely on China's vast pool
of factory workers for manufactured goods
and its consumers
represent a growing market
for western-made cars and luxury goods.
- A declining Chinese
population would mean
that there will be fewer
workers to make products
that are exported to other countries
and there will be fewer consumers,
especially younger consumers,
to buy goods from other countries.
- [Narrator] In the coming decades,
demographers expect China
will face a huge worker to retiree gap.
In 2020, 14% of China's
population was over 64 years old.
While in India, just 7%
of people were over 64.
By 2070, nearly 59% of people in China
will be over the age of 64.
While in India, only 30% of the population
will be in the same age bracket.
- A larger group of retirees will mean
that younger Chinese people
will have a bigger of a burden
to support the elderly.
That's especially true in the rural areas.
- [Narrator] In some ways,
India looks like China did 30 years ago.
It has a rapidly expanding
working age population
with 610 million people under age 25
and relatively few older
people to care for.
India's rising population
means it's likely to
keep its economy growing,
buy more of the world's goods
and play a bigger role in global affairs.
But India's rise isn't assured.
- India's problem now is all about jobs.
Yes, it does have a large
working age population
but at the same time it is struggling
to create jobs for its young people.
- [Narrator] India is
primarily a rural nation
and still lags behind
China in urbanization.
Unlike China, where
millions of migrant laborers
move to cities to work in factories,
many Indians are reluctant
to leave their hometowns.
India also significantly lags behind China
in terms of female labor participation.
India's cultural norms
have meant that families
who can't afford to keep their daughters
and wives at home prefer to do so.
- When Mao took power,
he really pushed the idea
that women is equal to men.
For a long time,
China's women labor participation
rate has been very high
and for India, that
seemed to be not the case.
- [Narrator] Whatever happens,
the world's future population
will be tilted more
towards the Global South
and South Asia, in particular.
In 2060, the three successor states
to pre-independence India
will have 2.3 billion people
versus China's 1.2 billion
guaranteeing profound changes
to the global economy.
(lively music)